good start for the d-backs two on and
one out for escobar
good at bat right there takes that
fastball up and in and they are loaded
for walker
dealing ground ball made for two at
second base flip to tatis
right on back to first base for the
double play you talk about just what he
needed
that's just what he got we're down here
in the bottom of the first inning
and it brings up trent grisham and he
drives one to deep right field
down the line and out of the yard a home
run
trent grisham's first in a padres
uniform with san diego on top one to
nothing
welcome to san diego trent grisham four
seamer middle and launch angle
no doubt that was straight
gwen stefani no doubt
lead off single here he's still at first
now with two men out
here's the tying run starly martay in
the air
shallow right oliveira's on on on and
dives can't get it off his glove
foul territory here comes ahmed around
third the throw to the plate he will
score
diamondback caught a break at dove in
front of edward oliveira is the rookie
playing just his second major league
game he almost made a diving grab but
the diamondbacks get the equalizer
and we're tied at one
monte winds up at third they credit him
with a double
escobar drives him home and make it 2-1
d-bags
it's a double for will myers padres half
second and third and nobody out
great rbi opportunity for greg garcia
right here
bunt bit down the first baseline a
safety squeeze will get a run
in and a base hit garcia beats it out
at first and taking third is myers game
tied two to two that'll work
how awesome is that great idea and it is
a bases loaded nobody out situation now
in a tie game oliveira's lanes went into
center field for a base hit
myers will score and the padres take a
3-2
lead two runs in nobody out chance to do
some real damage now
there is tatis jr two balls and two
strikes
weaver set at the belt now the pitch
swinging a hard hit liner through
the left side for a base hit ahmed dole
couldn't get there garcia comes in to
score
now he is being waved as it found its
way all the way to the wall
and right behind him olivares tatis into
third with a basis clearing triple
and just like that the padres have come
all the way back
and take a 6-2 lead boy that's a shocker
fernando tatis jr creating excitement
at the ball yard so well the one out a
single in a walk brings up escobar who
has walked and singled he's knocked in a
run
starting to chip away back on cal cuatro
here
trying to make some noise here in the
fifth and a swing and a miss needed that
strikes out escobar
first strikeout for cal cuatro two down
popped up left side machado steps onto
the infield grass
and makes the catch it ends the inning
cal quantrill doing a great job
6-2 padre fires his lead he runs the
pitch is popped up
and they yell to myers to get back
coming on is peralta and on the run
david makes the catch
and goes down but hangs on gets it back
in myers back to first two out of the
inning
kind of a tough pop-up it's out there in
short left center field
and it didn't look like starling could
get to that ball
and peralta barely got to the ball he
caught it betty padres take a 6-2 lead
to the ninth inning
and craig stamen becomes pitcher number
five of the day for san diego
there's a grounder right side to his
left garcia
and the throw in time for out number one
well you gotta love those
one pitch outs especially in the ninth
inning ring that bell down
fly ball headed to left field tommy fam
towards the line
on a slant wind playing with it a little
bit but he makes the catch two down
he's wearing a mask nice playing by the
rules that's a big mask
that is in the air to right field
oliveira's waiting on it
padres win they take three out of four
from the arizona diamondbacks to begin
the 2020 season
and an impressive fashion today a big
fourth inning a five run inning
and fans saluting them from across the
street
in downtown san diego fernando tatis jr
with a bases clearing triple
all part of a san diego 6-2 win